the majority of men in those countries
are grabbing girls 100
100
grave 100 you the majority of men you
know what grabbing girls I would like to
say this you are a misandrist I swear to
God you can say that you believe in
equality you can
you get but when you say it when you say
[ __ ] like that that is open Miss Andrea
against men and I don't stand for that
[ __ ] I have brothers I have fathers my
dad I employ people in other countries
my dad I grew up around people that were
employed from other countries and
including India which is one of the
countries that she talked about and that
is open with Sandra that is open with
Andrew that is not how men are that is
not how the majority of men are and you
saying that is open with Sandy against
men and and women if if a woman did the
same thing or if if a man did the same
thing about women people would have a
Heyday but you can come on a podcast and
just freely speak blatant sexism as my
mom say she always attracts flies pretty
of men in those countries are committing
assault yes that's your view on men no
no that's not okay okay and so then I
clarified it even more just to be sure
you're saying the majority of men in
those countries commit assault and she
said yes yes
poor women over there all those women
over there get get interviews by all of
those men every single man and her
evidence for it is she walked down a
street one time and one person did
something no no
stats oh the men all the men were going
through wherever she went in India all
the men the majority the majority of men
were going for the majority men were
grabbing her wherever she went she went
to India they grabbed her she can't go
anywhere without a man grabbing her in
India they do I will say I have been
India they do come up to you a lot but
it's like I remember when I went to
India and this is this is the difference
of like the two type of the type of
woman you can be I went to India and I
had a great time I was called Beautiful
more than I've ever been called
beautiful in my life they didn't grab me
they were just like oh you're so
beautiful you're so because there aren't
many like white people in it yeah so
they're like oh your skin your hair
you're beautiful you're beautiful you're
beautiful everywhere and I'm not gonna
say oh I was assaulted oh this this and
this no they give you a compliment now
look it I was I tried I mean I was 18 at
the time but was I attracted to most of
the men that did that no but I didn't
say assault I'll say thank you I went to
Tenerife and the same thing happened to
me wherever I went I kept on getting
approached but what she's not saying is
that when you go to these places a
tourist and you get approached all the
time they want to sell you something
they want to sell you something true
actually and they always want to sell
you something whatever I went in Morocco
something in America it's sunglasses
you've got sunglasses you want this
whatever you want they will approach you
all the time I could not walk along the
seafront without being approached about
10 times did I think I was really
attractive that all these men are
approaching me no they were selling
stuff but what she said is yes to
majority of men being assaulters yeah
that was the word assault they were
grabbing her that is completely
different than I switched it for you you
know yeah and she maybe that was two
maybe that was too click B I don't know
I don't know I switched it to the
majority okay you're welcome you're
welcome and man that's cultural
differences in my country even where
women's rights are not like well I'm not
I'm not here saying women are equal to
me I'm saying but if a woman doesn't
want to be touched don't touch her
that's even a religious side if you
don't touch it I'm with you yes I think
I've got a feeling that trauma's gonna
come up in them countries where what
countries even parts of Asia Africa can
you name them
and this is what they'll do they'll make
broad statements so when I say okay you
made the statement is this manipulative
to say when you okay this is happening
in these countries because normally half
the time when girls say this [ __ ]
they've never been to this country and
I'll tell you this was an educated
moment that I had in my life I always
heard [ __ ] about Saudi Arabia right I
was always like I always heard that it
was horrible and I interviewed zubi like
two years ago on my channel for the
first time and he grew up in Saudi
Arabia and he said it's actually not
that bad and he told me things about
Saudi Arabia I had no idea about so if I
went on a podcast and started spewing
[ __ ] about a country I'd barely been to
or maybe been to once or you know I
would look pretty ignorant I went to
Ghana I had a great time at the locals I
met some great men I made some great
friends no one approached me nobody
grabbed me everybody was friendly like
family Oh Yes actually I love Ghana I
actually fitted in Uganda so when she's
saying even Africa they grab you they
remember very respectful let's see let's
see what country she says travel
I've had men approach me millions and
I've said no no no Millions can she
count Millions even if you go on holiday
for a week two weeks even if you go on
holiday for a year count it can you is
it possible to be approached millions of
times even if you had one a second one a
minute how long is that that she's gonna
get approached what makes her better
than me how come she gets the first spot
millions of guys and I might get
approached by 10. and this is this is
the thing Auntie she could have just
said in this podcast you know what maybe
I misspoke yeah maybe I'm wrong but
modern women have this need to be right
at all costs Millions even even when
they're like oh I'm from Morocco and
she's got Moroccans sitting next to her
and she's still saying no no no no this
has happened Millions
you said you said wait wait you said you
said grabbed they were they were right
even in Dubai they grabbed one of my
friends I've been to Dubai I was fine I
had no issues yeah exactly what I'm
saying again and I went with my family
family sorry yeah
differences are when it comes to even
like me traveling as an Asian woman they
don't see me as my British passport they
see me as an Asian woman if I go to
Dubai they see me as a Bangladeshi woman
and they I don't believe that because
that she don't just like her if she
dressed like a Bangladeshi woman
normally does traditionally she wouldn't
get that but when you go with you're
testing Lycra they're gonna reproach you
yeah and that's the other thing like
I've been to when I was 18 I went to
Italy and
um it was so hot that I was in like
shorts and literally like this is a
cultural difference we would go to see
the churches they would and I know I
didn't know I didn't know I didn't know
like that they would just wave at you
like get out in the air yeah because you
have to cover up it's respectful I know
I should have but I don't know I was 18
I just in the US
did the same thing yeah yeah but that's
that's the thing like different cultures
like different things are acceptable and
before you go somewhere find out what
the culture is front you can look at
pictures find out what the local women
are wearing find out the Traditions I
mean that's why a lot of people have
problems when they go to Dubai because
they don't find out what the culture is
When in Rome you know do as a Romans do
so you can't go somewhere and say well
you know because I've got a [ __ ]
passport I can do what I like no you
can't no and that's the thing like I
could have been mad oh they're
discriminating against women
no no no
it was real hot Auntie it was so hot I
bet you look hot as well in a church in
shorts how dare you it's funny but when
you go to some Churches in the Caribbean
you know and you're not covered I've
been to certain churches and as soon as
oh no they get a scarf and cover your
head yeah you know yeah they cover my
head when I go in and then you go in the
church you realize that all the women
said to cover that just in case you're a
visitor rather than offend you which
they do sometimes when they cover my
head they just cover your head take
advantage of that thinking I'm a
Bangladeshi woman it's just interesting
um because I know a couple people from
those countries and they don't actually
have the same views as you
grew up in the like like um I wish you'd
stop saying 100 she just stopped saying
100 interrupts you every time you talk
on every fix 100 100 you know a lot of
people will get me for that mm-hmm
because that's what I do
um that sounds like a black thing it's a
black thing so a lot of black people do
that I do it too like I'm listening but
yeah I know it doesn't but it's okay
it's better than this 100
I think you said Morocco can I just say
yes
majority I'll say this the context in
which this happened you were on holiday
right and you're saying that people
grabbed you what was the context of that
group no I'm not saying that they can't
you see it you see now she's been found
out she's like [ __ ] I'm next to an
actual Moroccan maybe she didn't expect
some Moroccan to look like that
approached a constantly trying to talk
yeah no no
do the majority of men assault now she's
switching it now she's switching it
because she realizes she said something
wrong instead of just saying I was wrong
she's gonna point the finger at Pearl
like I made you say this wild [ __ ] on my
podcast what can I say as a Moroccan
were you a tourist were you in a tourist
area were you in the Medina where
they're approaching you to sell you
things what no I'll just walk in the
beach I was walking the beach even if
it's a tour whenever you go on holiday
and there's a beach people are going to
approach you to show you something
wherever you go in the whole world and I
will say the majority of places that you
go to if you're on the beach somebody
will approach you at some point to sell
you something it's just you disrespect
it area what I'm saying is some
countries like even just say when I go
Bangladesh and I'm not a tourist and I'm
in my own country clothes everything
guys will still feel like they can they
have a right to come and speak to you
do you know something right when you go
to these places as a married woman they
show you some respect when you go to
India I've got Indian friends you get
you get treated differently if you've
left your husband or if you're divorcee
I've no women to stay in a marriage even
though they're separated don't get
divorced so their children can go back
and enjoy the culture because sometimes
you get treated differently if you're a
divorce woman if you split up with your
husband or if you're a single parent you
will get treated differently in certain
cultures and that's a fact 100
I'm not saying it's wrong I'm saying
again look at social cues if like you
said the guys teaching girls what
signaling is if she's not making eye
contact if she's not don't maybe don't
approach her especially and that's how
you make know what your signals are
according to where you're going because
certain signals are different in
different places that you go to it's for
you
the situation that I was describing
because you're kind of like me tooing
these guys because they approached okay
can I just say as a victim who has been
sexually abused as a trauma
old it's yeah it is deep it is deep and
I don't want if I